we're having a dilemma my mom will not
let me go sleep outside at the Apple
Store tomorrow mommy what if what if we
hmm your hairless daddy said I could go
daddy said I could go you've got one
thanks daddy
you two do you want to come with this
would be a fun trip grandma will know
that love the whole family and we'll all
just be free that she's skipping for you
am I on
yeah well anyway a new iPhone comes up
tomorrow I'm pretty excited except
here's the dilemma is I fell asleep when
I was doing my pre-order so I didn't
order it until two o'clock I wanted the
rose gold 1:28 and it wouldn't ship
until mid-october and the problem is I'm
not going to be at the location of where
the phone was being shipped and it won't
let you change the address unless I
don't know it's it's a complicated
system because if your billing address
is different than your shipping address
they won't let you ship I don't know
it's a little frustrating I also saw a
couple of people on Twitter were
complaining about the same problem but
either way this problem can be resolved
by going and camping out it would be a
mini campout
I mean I just think that it's a mini
campout whole sleepy should we start
packing up now it's 11:00 11:30 a.m.
remember this time last year I think
this is what I got heatstroke yeah yeah
although it was a year ago
like a week ago here go with you yeah
cool I'm gonna figure this out Apple
store I'm not sure when you say it
clearly
find me the nearest Apple store here is
what I found
61 miles away do you think they're open
I think they're open all right let's
give them a call oh yeah sorry if
anybody's in line yet for the only thing
you're especially thank you you mouth
your call correctly please tell me the
reason for your call I want an ID oh man
little man hello everyone so vacation is
going well hanging out with the family
doing lots of fun stuff it's in raining
a little bit but it's been fun just kind
of like hanging on the house playing a
little Maddy and now we're gonna take it
to the vet because Brianne insists on
taking you to the bed Briana's attack
every week she's big go to the vet every
single week which is probably better to
be safe than sorry he's feeling okay
he's just been so itchy lately so he
looks a little bit he looks a little
ratchet right now because we've got some
oils in him for his little dry skins
this is a special time because usually
you're always in your car seat
oh you're biting so hard biting so bad
there's a kitty in there
oh hi kitty kitty kitty
gosh the vet is fun huh somebody
was such a good boy that's you that's
you you look like a possum in the bag
that he was so good he got his little
paws all checked up and guess what no
parasites no nothing so it's got to be
an allergy so we're gonna stop giving
him the goat's milk which was
recommended to give Tim originally we're
gonna do that anymore no more milk ease
for you baby do you see what I see the
Harris Teeter I'm mature what we needed
to get here other than Starbucks I'm
pretty sure that was the only thing but
I do want to see if they have guapi
let's see behavior of every yerba Yerba
where's the drinks drinks drinks drinks
drinks drinks I have embarrassed myself
so many times in this life I don't think
I'll be doing a music video this year
but if I do you guys will be the first
coffee tea iced coffee with almond milk
excuse me yeah you see if it's good
what's up yeah are you it's buy one get
one free but I don't need to okay then
you don't need it you don't need it it's
free
yeah but you don't need it do you need
it's decorating no it's free
okay feel like I should do one but we
you don't need it do you need it No
if there's one thing that Maddie doesn't
need is another toy but look at this
look at this tire look at this oh go
ahead
really does he like it you see he ate it
he's going to do it Maddy doesn't do
that yet so let's get it for him
you think you'd like it
no much toys here No
look at this pig oh my god disgusting
don't like it should get our PSL are you
gonna place a piezo yeah I think I'm
gonna get a PSL first PSL of the season
he had one cut really new cup okay so
what do we do now
they are the infamous sugar cookies kids
of all ages can choose from two
delicious varieties I think I'm a child
I think I'm a child for kids of all ages
if I think I'm a child I'm actually a
child
where's his toy at of course any time we
go and you ever got to get Maddie a new
toy what's this you might be afraid of
it get-get all day all day all day
all done Janice is talking I can't talk
all Jennifer talking about is cutting
the cake since we got it this morning
there's cake okay I'll take this one are
you Lee holding are you excited for the
iPhone launch tomorrow Oh baby
so not only is tomorrow the iPhone
launch but it's also the launch of
Lizzy's movie her movie comes out
tomorrow dies yes I'm trying to cry
because I'm just thinking about it but
going to a screening and seeing how much
it impacts people and how Lizzie is able
to inspire people we have a screening
tomorrow of it family screening okay
oh I thought Maddie
whoa are you excited to see Lizzy's
movie kiss it Lizzy has a puppy named
oli that looks you are a little little
excited bit like you can bite my face
off because he's excited for the movie
excited for the movie and iPhone
tomorrow make sure you guys check out
I'm with Lizzy calm so you can see if
it's playing in a theater near you it is
lying in a few select cities so
hopefully playing near you guys and you
can go see it mmm
what is Mel I'll see you guys tomorrow
for iPhone day and Lizzy day I hope you
guys are all doing awesome
wait checking for updates all right
we'll have to download it first teach
Wi-Fi is not work